we're looking today as you can see at
Compass of figures now I just want you
to remember you know I'm so much about
words and like where they come from and
what they made composite just means
anything that is made up of comprised of
more than one thing if you put some
things together you're like I've got
more than one thing you put together you
call that a composite for example one of
the most famous composite materials is
something that you've walk on pretty
much every day here in Australia when
you get to school were you like walking
out onto the playground what kind of
material do your feet touch so know what
it's called it's called concrete right
but some of you may not realize concrete
is not just one thing it's made up of
two particular parts you know where the
big truck which spins right it comes
along and it's it's spinning because
something inside it will set if it stays
still what's that thing inside it submit
very good but cement by itself it's not
as strong as if you mix it with
something you make it a composite with
something now this is a word you
probably haven't seen before and it can
mean a whole bunch of different things
often it's sand or maybe like some small
pebbles and rocks and that kind of thing
as a general term we call that aggregate
I think it's a double G I agree get that
that r's not supposed to be there there
we go
aggregate I can spell so you put svet
together without it you get concrete and
that's a composite material now when you
have composite figures we're not talking
about mixing substances together we're
talking about mixing shapes which
includes of course numbers that go with
the shapes there are two basic
strategies you've probably seen this
before so I'm gonna go through it quite
quickly two basic strategies for working
out the areas that's what I'm really
focusing on the moment of shapes like
this okay either you kids say well
they're composite because you added
things together you could say well this
is the addition of a bunch of shapes can
we work out what each of the shapes is
and then just add them together and
that's not too hard okay but there is
another way that's very similar and this
is something you can't do with materials
but you can do with shapes what else
might you do apart from addition Marek
these pipelines so you can't actually
predict how how much is like one looks
almost I need eyes if you have wait wait
this one no no wait wait this one this
one yeah very good okay we're gonna do
exactly that in one second actually Iram
take Merrick suggestion but before I do
that let hit pause on it what's the
opposite of addition it's subtraction
right now here's a cool thing you can do
with shapes that you cut so much to do
with concrete you can think of this Eddy
almost any composite figure as not just
putting figures together like adding
them but also starting with one big
shape and then taking parts out of it
I'm going to illustrate that with you
right now which is why I've got so many
of these one last thing these are the
two basic strategies but sometimes
particular shape that you've got you can
combine these two as well sometimes you
add and you subtract to make whatever
shape that you happen to have so let's
have a look at this guy now Merritt gave
us the suggestion I'm drawing this
imaginary line I think this is the one
you were doing is that correct
Mary cuz that one you're afraid too
great now what you can see is we have
divided this composite figure into two
pieces and what's great about both
pieces is that they're both shapes that
you know what are they they're both
rectangles right fantastic
now this rectangle over here you have
its dimensions don't you what are the
dimensions of this left-hand rectangle a
and five very good so this let's call
these guys let's give them some names
right so I'm just going to number them
you could call them a and B if you like
but I'm gonna say area one because it's
a rectangle the eight into five what do
i do then how do I combine them so does
it yeah Jessica very good I'm going to
multiply eight cool their meters okay
sorry
eight meters by 5 meters which gives me
an area for of we could all say it right
40 square meters thank you very much but
that's just one part so now I've got the
other bit me record we gonna do this
under the one I draw another line ah
okay so let me come to that right you
could draw another line but do you see I
sort of don't need to at this point like
I've divided up a weird-looking l-shaped
thing into two nice shapes that I can
already deal with okay I'm gonna come to
your other line in a minute can someone
tell me how to do this one Harry say
that again so the bottom at the top will
be five very good where did we get five
from by the way how did you calculate
that here very good yeah so how easy
Chuck we're and Hanks explained how I
love you to put all your diagram not
just that this is five it's actually Tim
take away that five it's a difference
right does that make sense just so
happens that ten take away five also
equal to five now we've got that leg we
could do the same thing that we did with
the first area and just say well that's
five times five meters times three
meters and we have it area down so I
would conclude this by saying I now want
to find out all of those together I'll
say the total area and I'm just going to
add them can you tell me what the total
be in this case 55 square meters thank
you very much all right okay now I will
just point out for a simple shape like
this you probably don't necessarily need
to have you know names for the areas you
maybe don't have to go all through that
working you could for example start your
first line as 8 times 5 plus 5 times 3
and then you'll get 55 you'll get the
same answer but the more complex your
shape is the more I'm going to encourage
you to set it out like this name your
shapes like describe them work that
independently and then combine the at
the end ok now the reason why I asked
you to draw and I've drawn more than one
copy here is that you can divide up this
shape in other ways now Marik was
suggesting putting a line a horizontal
one underneath the one so we would get
something like this now we don't need
the working for this because we already
know what the total area is but I would
love us to actually think about how
we can still arrive at the same answer
now Mary you've given us the suggestion
for this one so I'm gonna hit pause on
you there one if someone else can
contribute so here do you haven't said
anything yet where could I go from here
yes okay so I could number them I could
say this is one of this is two I'm even
going to not do that because I know we
don't need the whole working here can we
work out can someone tell me what this
bottom one is the second area it's 30 so
I got that for three times 10 30 square
meters and can someone tell me we're
missing a woman's your dimension for the
top one aren't we
what are we missing yeah Louise what do
you see yeah very good
yep doesn't go all the way yep so this
is eight minus three so that gives us
five sorry my scale that's not very good
obviously but the measurements the
lengths that are on there tell me so
what is this actual area which is 25
square meters and of course we can check
that and you still get you same 55 three
diagrams because there's one last way to
do it Christian idea if your pen up just
for thinking or to suggest a way to do
this just for thinking okay all right so
you just gave us that answer so can
someone else show us remember we said
you can do this a by addition so we've
so far added these two and that's giving
us the same answer how could I use
subtraction here yeah
Square yes directions and then fantastic
so there's like an extra in each case
you can see there's extra stuff that
I've drawn it in red but depending on
where you draw it if you draw it inside
the shape you're gonna add up these
areas but if you draw these dots outside
the shape like so that missing corner
then we're going to subtract do you have
a question or a thought
just just Richard okay all right before
you do that who are you looking for what
yeah can I see what he needs to do okay
do you do you know what his offices
yeah yet near the stupid done yeah okay
thank you okay so before I asked Louise
is everyone who hasn't said anything yet
who'd be able to contribute a thought on
this one over here just can you said
something already someone who hasn't I'm
gonna go to the back hater
we've got you you de facto enough to do
all that much working because to work
out this guy here this shape which I'm
going to shade in here maybe you want to
do the same we've already worked done
all the work in the previous diagrams to
work out the dimensions of this can you
read off the dimensions for me what
would be on what would the height of
this guy been very good we work that out
yeah and Tim can you tell me what's the
width here again we've already worked
this out but can you show me what it is
also five so they're going to square up
there so this guy up here this is going
to be 25 square meters because 5 times 5
right but now if you look over all the
big shape including this like extra
corner which lengths are we going to use
to multiply together to get the big
shape okay wait
very good 10 times 8 these are the
longest lengths so this whole big thing
I'm just going to put it over here is 80
square meters right but remember we're
doing this by subtraction not by
addition so what am I going to do with
80 and 25 hello come on Haley yeah
fantastic 80 takeaway 25 does it give us
the right answer
fifty-five still that's reassuring I've
got the same shape every time so no
matter which way we go about it we get
the same area okay you guys know how you
guys know how I love that game where you
take the digits of the date and I say
can you make 100 you know that right
we're not going to do that right now but
I love that idea so much because it
requires me to create unity so I'm gonna
base something on it that we're gonna do
right now I want you to think that your
first name your first name just think
about your first name how you spell it
you very familiar with it okay what I
would like to do is to you get you to
take your first name and use composite
figures to write out your first name and
make a hundred square units now you
don't call me by my first name you call
me by this name so I took probably
longer than I should have this morning
to work out how to use composite figures
to make an area of 100 square units
using the letters and I cheated a little
bit by using some punctuation with my
name now I didn't just like eyeball it
and said I reckon that looks about a
hundred I had to do a fair bit of work
here is me working out that this is a
hundred square units you can see just
like we did before
sometimes I'm adding shapes together
sometimes I am subtracting shapes and
depending on how you want to do this you
can make it as simple or as complicated
as you like I'll give you two well yeah
two tips my first tip is which is you
will see actually I didn't do it very
well that's why I know to give you this
tip work out how many letters there are
in your name right and my suggestion to
you is the first thing is divide 100 by
that so that all of your letters are
going to be roughly the same area you
can see I didn't do that so when I got
to the end I was like oh no my O's need
to be very fat to take over that area
because I was like oh I'm not gonna read
100 so that's why they're kind of um
they look a bit like square doughnuts
okay so that's that's the first thing
the second thing is you know how to
calculate the area of a bunch of
different shapes and I hope you can see
in the previous exercise I think we
looked at what do you look at squares
what are the shapes triangles
parallelograms and rectangles I think it
was those four
okay now what I'd like you to do is add
a minimum I'd like you to use all four
of those shapes